>> From the Library of
congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Michael Cavna: Came from Carolina
but went to school here at MICA
and while she was still there
had a dream for a web comic
and it just flat out
took off, it just --
she creates characters
that resonate with readers,
she defies expectation, she has a
vision, she knows what she's doing
and that led to Nimona which
recently was a finalist --
yes, a finalist for the
National Book Award,
a big hand for that I think.
[ Applause ]
And you may know her as well
for her work on Lumberjanes,
he fantastic work and we're
going to sit down and we're going
to talk about these successes.
She's also written for
Marvel, she has other projects,
she is in Hollywood, she's --
everything she creates seems
to be option for films.
Our hope is between live action
and animation people, smart people,
talented people will bring
her vision to the screen
and she will just continue rising.
It is my true pleasure to bring
to the stage for the first time
on this stage, Noelle Stevenson.
[ Applause ]
>> Noelle Stevenson: Which chair
do it sit in, where am I going?
>> Michael Cavna: Go
there, go there.
>> Noelle Stevenson: This
chair is as good as any other.
>> Michael Cavna: Well,
thank you so much.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Hi,
guys, thank you for coming,
now you can be [inaudible]
it says you're here.
>> Michael Cavna: He's easier
to find, we know where he is.
But thank you so much, you know
we were talking the other day,
what moves me is people's origin
stories and I'm always fascinated
when -- like I was a kid my parents
threw so much pop culture at me
and so much art and it
was sort of a gluttony
of getting to see everything.
You had the opposite experience
right, your parents were
like no Disney films, not much TV,
I think what Scooby-Do was
one of the few exceptions.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I mean
I was raised in South Carolina,
I have four brothers and sisters
and we were all home schooled.
So you know we were kind of a --
it was the whole movement of people
who -- we weren't allowed to read
Harry Potter when I was growing
up because it would teach
you to be a witch obviously.
I think I was not allowed
to watch Pocahontas
after my little sister saw it
at a sleep over and came home
and said mommy did you
know you could pray
to trees, so no more Pocahontas.
I got a baby sitter fired for
letting me watch Power Puff girls.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Yeah so it wasn't like --
I don't know if it was an across
the board ban on, you know,
all kid's movies, like kid's media,
but it certainly wasn't
a really wide open world
that I was partaking in.
The first movie I saw in
theaters was the Prince of Egypt.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Because it was about God.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Noelle Stevenson: and it was
great, I mean I was obsessed with it
and there's a lot of like instant
murder and naked man butts in it so,
you know but it was about God.
>> Michael Cavna: You can have
that but you can't pray to trees
but you can have man butt.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yes,
because it was about God.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, it
was all good, but they mellowed
out as I got older, yeah now they're
so mellow, they are like too mellow.
I come home and my mom puts a drink
in my hand [inaudible]
where's my real mom?
>> Michael Cavna: Did
they change or did you?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I
think that the kids --
I think that they were
hippies before they had kids
and then they wanted to be
like the good Christian parents
and raise their kids right
and they did that for a while
and then they got tired of it.
And then they were just like
let's just be hippies again,
our kids are already, you know --
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah
and your parents are --
>> Noelle Stevenson:
They're just going
to do whatever they're going to do.
>> Michael Cavna: Well, your
parents were next to you
at the National Book Award
ceremony right last year?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Right.
>> Michael Cavna: And
they looked happy.
They looked like they were chilling.
Maybe drinking with you.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Oh,
oh, yes, my little sister,
I could only get tickets -- I mean
I wanted they said I could only have
one ticket, I will bring my
mom because I promised her
that she could come but then
my dad is like I want to come.
So I was like I'll pull strings
and get you a ticket,
I got my dad a ticket.
And they're like oh your
sisters are coming with us,
I'm like I can't get, I
can't get two more tickets,
this is a really expensive event.
So my sisters like snuck in.
and my little sister
she works as a waitress,
so she worked as a
waitress at the time,
so she had a white tuxedo
jacket which happened
to be exactly what the
waiters were wearing.
So my little sister infiltrates
the rings of the waiters
and at some point I just
hear somebody go shots.
And like three shots are set down
in front of me and my parents
and I look up and she's like
disappearing again into the crowd.
>> Michael Cavna: So when a good
family goes bad they go really bad.
That is amazing, so I mean you
were drawing, what I love again
with origins stories is
like if you don't get
to see anything except the
occasional Disney man butt,
where do you go, well you were
drawing like stick figures.
We talked about I think wild
rollercoaster rides, maybe ants
or decapitations or something.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I had an
ongoing series that I wrote,
filled several notebooks
with it was a story of an ant
who was traumatized
by rollercoasters.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: But he
wanted to overcome his fear
for rollercoasters so he would
like ride more rollercoasters
and they would always crash in
terrible ways and this ant would get
like mangled and he was just like
three little black dots with arms
and legs and antenna coming out.
So I would just -- all of his
body parts would go everywhere,
like in different train
cars and then he'd be
like no more rollercoasters, he's
have like this little ant cast on.
And then like rollercoasters comes
in the middle of the grocery store
and like scoop him up and he'd
have to ride the next one.
It was very gruesome.
>> Michael Cavna: Now you
were like 5 or 6 though right.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah I
didn't know how to write yet,
all I could write was like I
drew my things was like broom,
I think was the only sound
effect, it was like broom
and you hear it coming
and it was like oh,
no and then a rollercoaster
would come.
>> Michael Cavna: Did you let
your parents see your comics?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I don't
think anyone else ever saw the ant
rollercoaster comics, I have
like a bunch of sketch books
that I kept all the time and my
siblings snooped through everything
so they might have seen it but --
>> Michael Cavna: If they can
infiltrate the National Book Awards
they can --
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, oh I
have the snoopiest family ever,
everyone goes through
each other's stuff.
I was like my little sister came out
to visit me last year and she was
like -- I was like talking about
something that had happened
when we were kids and I was
like this is secretly how I felt
about it, I didn't want
to tell anyone that.
She says oh I know
I read your journal.
>> Michael Cavna: They're
just open too.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I think she has
like a bright future ahead of her
as like a spy or like a private
investigator or something.
>> Michael Cavna: Or your
lawyer or agent I think --
>> Noelle Stevenson: She
did do my hair and makeup
for the National Book Awards.
>> Michael Cavna: Nice.
>> Noelle Stevenson: It was
this whole like bouffant thing,
it was great, it was cool.
>> Michael Cavna: Would
you let her do that again?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Oh, totally, yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: So
there are family skills,
so you're there you're being
home schooled, did you --
like were you sneaking out comic,
I think you said you were about 11
when you went to your
first comic book store?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I don't know
how old I was, I would have been --
I was into Star Wars at the time,
I was going for Star Wars action
figures, I wasn't going for comics.
And I went to the one comic
shop that was in my town,
it was called like --
I don't know it looks
like a big castle with
a dragon on top.
It was really cool and they had like
a huge Jaba which I really wanted.
And I remember the first thing
I saw when I walked in was
like a cardboard cutout of Princess
Leia in her like metal bikini.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: And she had
a sign taped over her belly button
with the like deals for the day
and I was like 11 and I was just
like oh, this is the kind
of place this is, I get it.
And like I didn't ever go back,
you know I wasn't even
like oh no not a bikini.
Like I've seen Star Was of course
but like you know I just got a
really clear message from that was
that this store wasn't for me.
I could go with like my friend's
older brothers but it was going
to be weird if I went by
myself, so I just didn't go back.
>> Michael Cavna: Not for you
in a male, female way, did it --
>> Noelle Stevenson: It was
like this is what girls look
like here you know,
and you get the --
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
You just get messages.
>> Michael Cavna: Is that shop
still there, have you been back?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah,
actually I went back,
I was looking for some random little
comic that I was reading at the time
and I go in and it
was kind of like --
it's got a lot of cardboard
boxes, like long boxes full
of like back issues, very,
very like hard core nerdy now.
And I went in and I was like so
nervous, I was like are they going
to be -- because it's a thing
you always do whenever you go
into comic shops, like are they
going to be nice to me this time.
>> Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: And the
guy behind the like counter,
he kind of looked like you know like
a little I don't know like unshaven
and I was like oh is
he going to be nice.
And he's like hi, how are you,
like what are you looking for,
and he's like oh you like
that comic try this one.
He was like so nice.
>> Michael Cavna: So it
was like totally different.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
He was introducing me
to like other comic book shoppers
in there and they were all like --
I was like this is great, I was
like so sorry that I judged you
because it's like a
weird dark basement.
But it was so great and I've
been in like the most trendy,
like brightly lit comic shops and
people have been terrible to me.
It's like you really can't
tell, sometimes it's just
like a little hidden gem of
people who really do want
to share their passion with you.
They really like want to like --
they want to like introduce
you to more comics,
like recommend more comics, so
that was an amazing feeling,
just feeling like oh you never know.
>> Michael Cavna: It's changed, I
saw a photo of the shop recently
and there was a dude in
a metal bikini out front
so I think it means things
have totally changed.
No, it is -- I remember going to
Comic-Con and talking to Stan Sakai
who had been going to
[inaudible] Comic-Con for decades
and he'd bring his family
and he said we were --
you know my wife was often
the only female there
and we've just seen you know this
revolution, do you feel a part
of a revolution, do you feel
you know, what do you feel,
what do you see as change occurs?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I mean I
would say more part of a wave,
so and like I managed to jump on,
on the wave as it was already
happening, so you know the part
that I jumped onto was web comics.
Web comics had been, it was
pretty new but you know 10,
15 years old by the time I started
dabbling in it and just so much
of the work had already been done.
You know people had figured out how
to have a web comic what the
format would typically be,
how to monetize it using ads
and kick start and patrion
and so it was already this really
rich community and I managed
to just kind of like
standing on the shoulders
of giants you know,
that's what it is.
It is like a lot of people
had laid the ground work.
>> Michael Cavna: Is there anyone
you look to artists, creators,
writers, anyone you look to?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Oh, yeah absolutely,
I mean Kate Beaten is
another guest here,
she's one of the first
web comic artists.
>> Michael Cavna: Hark,
a vagrant, among others.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah,
Tony Cliff's book, Delilah Dirk
and the Turkish Lieutenant
was the first like serialized,
fantasy-ish comic that I
read that made me think
that I could do something
like that, you know.
And then you know there's Yuko
& Anath from Johnny Wander.
Jess Fink, Ryan North
all of the old greats
who were working ten
years before me,
back in the olden days
of web comics.
And they were, you know it was
just such a welcoming world
when I came into it and yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: So you're in
sought Carolina, you're in Columbia
until you're about roughly 18 right.
>> Noelle Stevenson: 17.
>> Michael Cavna: And then you go
off to MICA and you're majoring
in illustration and did
it feel like any sort
of cultural shift or you know --
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, you feel
like okay and now I'm in art camp.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I mean I showed
up and like the first college party
that I went to there were
clippers and they were just dolling
out undercuts -- I woke up
the next day and my wrong bed,
with half my head shaved, I was like
this is the best part of last night,
it's the one thing noticed.
But yeah no it was completely
different it was like --
I mean I came from South
Carolina, I came from a little bit
of like country club area and
like where everything was very --
it was just really controlled,
what I would respond to and a lot
of my friends would go to Christian
schools with the assumption
that you know if you
are exposed to sins you.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
You will become sinful
so you'd better not expose yourself
to that at all, which is just,
I don't know just strikes me as
like terribly backwards thinking.
Like I don't know how
you can have so much --
have like real faith if
you don't trust yourself
to be out in the real world.
But the place that I did go it was
a place of undercuts and a place
of tattoos that you administered
yourself and it was a place
of you know really, really
queer students as well.
And everything changed, it
was like you know I have
to reexamine every single
thing that I've grown up with
because I know these people
now, they're my friends.
So you know I have to reconsider
every single thing I've ever
learned, I was wrong about
everything and it just tore me
down to the base and
like built me up again.
And I'm still you know trying
to reevaluate as often as I can
because I don't want to --
>> Michael Cavna: So did you
start going out every night
and testing your faith with --
>> Noelle Stevenson: Well, my
faith got pretty well tested,
it was no longer much
of a thing, but yeah.
Yeah, I guess I should have
gone to Christian school.
>> Michael Cavna: So when did you --
you know, Nimona just what's amazing
to me is how you can
take something --
some things emerge and they just see
fully formed and Nimona just comes
across as one of those
things that you just,
from wherever it sprang you just had
such vision for it and such vision
for Nimona as a character.
I think you've talked about going
through certain times of interviews
where you said you hated certain
female characters and you didn't
like what you were seeing, can
you just talk about the creation
of Nimona and what maybe
you were reacting to.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I mean it
all came out of just like, I guess,
a fateful collision of different
influences that I had at the time.
I mean one of them was that
Halloween was coming up and I wanted
to dress, I wanted to dress up for
Halloween of course, it's a big deal
at our school, everyone
goes crazy on their costumes
and makes something
really elaborate.
And I was like I dressed up
as a male character every year
for Halloween, I've never dressed
up as a female character before
because I don't feel comfortable
in the clothes that a lot
of female characters' wear.
And even if I do it's like
most of them have long hair,
I have short hair, like
where are the characters
who look a little bit more like me?
And I think I probably
dressed up as Hawkeye
or something that year anyway.
But it was like on my mind that
I wanted to design somebody
who was iconic and just
looked a little bit different
from the other heroines
that I had to pick from.
And so that was kind of on my
mind and then also I was --
drawing like this Joan of Arc
type character a lot of the time.
It was just like a medieval
interest that I was just exploring
and so I went to a class and they
were like all right you're going
to make a character in 30
minutes, I was like all right.
You know, and it just came out,
like she just appeared actually
the character had existed before,
I had a character in high
school, whose name was Night Shade
and she was a shapeshifter,
she wore an eye patch
and she was really cool,
she was just like so cool.
>> Michael Cavna: Did you
cast her as Night Shade?
>> Noelle Stevenson: No I mean she
had never really been anything,
I had never even really drawn
her, it was just like an idea
and so I was like I
want to do something
with this character who's kind
of been floating around for a bit
but I've never had a story, she's
not been with other characters.
And so she emerged for this project
and it kind of combined those ideas,
I think she'd be like a super hero
because the original
one had been more
of a standard super hero
universe and then it --
I was like oh I'll make it medieval
and that added this interesting
flavor I think that took it a step
above the typical you know,
deconstructing the super hero.
Like generic buildings, and
wear a T-shirt and like yeah.
So yeah and it just -- you know
after the assignment was done I was
like oh I like this character, I'm
going to see where this takes me.
>> Michael Cavna: Well, can you talk
about like we're saying this image
if we can go to that
you know and her look.
I don't know if she ever had
an undercut but you know --
>> Noelle Stevenson: The whole
back of her head is an undercut.
>> Michael Cavna: Exactly, so
the whole look can you talk
about you know as your -- you have
just a beautiful sense of design
and your characters, you have the
gift, you feel your characters,
you feel Ballister,
you know you feel sort
of this easy arrogance privilege
of Goldenloin right you know
so could you talk about
like you know when you --
her look and what you're
trying to do there
and what you've succeeded at?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, her
looks stayed pretty much the same,
it was really important to
me that she was like chunky,
just because that was
one of the things
that I like can't see as often.
And it's really fun to draw frankly.
But she stayed pretty
much unchanged,
I think her first iteration
she had a different,
if anyone remembers read the
web comics she had a little bit
of a different look on the first
few pages and then I changed it
to give her -- she's the most
anachronistic character in the comic
but I did want to give her a little
bit of almost like a pageboy.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Effect to her hair cut,
so that's where that
haircut came from,
still with the punk element though.
Yeah and it's funny because
I was like talking about how
like I wanted her to be
cosplayable and then I was
like yeah she's not
going to wear pants.
And this was like really
funny to me,
the first two pages I had not
slept in like three weeks so I
like it was really funny to me
that she wasn't wearing pants,
I don't remember what the joke was
but there was some kind of joke.
And then I also like gave her the
shaved which no cosplayer ever wants
to like commit that
hard to, you know.
So kind of shot myself
in the foot there,
making like the ultimate
cosplay character.
Not that that you know should
really form your decisions
when you are designing somebody.
But yeah I mean she stayed
pretty much the same,
it was just like how can I combine
medieval elements with the some more
like punk elements, you know.
>> Michael Cavna: And
I like the sense
that you know Ballister you
think he's going to be this free
for all super villain
and that he has rules
and he has standards and --
>> Noelle Stevenson: No
one was more disappointed
than Nimona to find that out.
>> Michael Cavna: Exactly yeah,
and he has pants on thankfully.
>> Noelle Stevenson: He does, most
of the other characters don't.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
I found that out, yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: So could you --
>> Noelle Stevenson: I put like
a fanny shot on the second page
of [inaudible] I don't know how
anyone let me get away with this.
>> Michael Cavna: You could
cosplay like that a MICA
but anywhere else I think.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I'm really
trying to remember I had like --
I told my friend I was like we
need to draw knights without pants,
this was really funny,
I don't remember why
and it must just be funny
when you haven't slept.
Which also explains the shark.
>> Michael Cavna: It all makes
sense now, so before you guys --
>> Noelle Stevenson: I'm
just destroying the magic
for everybody, no thought
went into it.
>> Michael Cavna: At some point try
reading this after just not sleeping
for a week and you may --
>> Noelle Stevenson:
It becomes way funnier.
>> Michael Cavna: So could you talk
about their relationship and that
because that's again very
immediately their dynamic was very
natural, can you talk about that?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I
think I was always very interested
in as the middle child of five,
I was very interested in the idea
of having like an older
parental figure
who would give you
their sole attention.
>> Michael Cavna: Another way your
parents didn't measure up or --
>> Noelle Stevenson: I mean
I was one of five, you can't,
you just cannot, I was the middle so
I Batman and Robin influence there.
Batman and Carrie Kelly specifically
which I kind of expected to like --
I thought I was being so obvious
about the Carrie Kelly thing
and thought I'd get called out
about it but it's actually not
that obvious now that
I look back at it.
At one point she wears like green
goggles and like yellow gloves,
I'm like this is such a
shout out and no one got it.
No one knows who Carrie Kelly
is I guess, I don't know.
>> Michael Cavna: Another thing
that in the moment was
just yeah [inaudible].
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, so it
was kind of a Batman and Robin,
it was kind of a there's a little
bit of mystic [inaudible] in there
and there's a little bit of a
[inaudible] from Impossible.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure.
>> Noelle Stevenson: So
those are all just kind
of the boss side kick relationships
that I was inspired by.
>> Michael Cavna: Nice, nice,
now in you know being 17, 18,
19 that can be a time of
enormous change and you were going
through change, it's just incredibly
cool that she's a shapeshifter
and what that speaks to, identity
and feelings toward identity.
Could even be identity politics,
can you talk a little bit
about why a shapeshifter?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Yeah, I mean that's --
it's the point of the whole
book I think is identity
and what was interesting to me
about Nimona was a spoiler like --
she doesn't have a default form,
which most shapeshifters do.
So you kind of assume because you
meet her as this girl that this is
who she really is but it isn't,
and I think that really --
because I did make Night Shade up
you know when I was in high school.
I had been homeschooled until
my junior year and then I want
to public high school for two years
and I just had no idea what I
was doing there, like who I was.
>> Michael Cavna: I just have
to -- how was that, was that --
>> Noelle Stevenson: I just skated
through, you know, I like didn't --
I was in the drama club
and the drama club is kind
of in a separate building away
from the rest of the school
and I would just cut class
all the time and like --
I was friends with the
librarian and the art teachers
and the drama teacher so I would
just cut class an go and read
or I'd cut class and go and like
-- I mean I always had a note
or something, I'd be like I'm
painting sets at drama club,
I'm working on a children's
book in art class.
So they would just let me walk out,
I was not used to sitting at a desk
and chair and having people be
like here's your worksheet,
do this in 30 minutes.
I'm like I'm done, can I go,
like no you have to stay.
I've been home schooled for this
long, my mom gives me a list
of things to do, I do them
and then I can go play.
Like I mean I was in high school
so I guess I wasn't like playing
but I want to go eat
a bagel or whatever.
>> Michael Cavna: By the way
have any of those teachers,
librarians have they seen
Nimona or have they seen --
have you heard from any of them?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I'm
a little bit in touch
with my high school art teacher,
really she was one who told me
like art school was a thing and
brought in art like [inaudible].
So she's like basically
the reason, she was the one
who showed me what
illustration was at all,
I didn't know it was a thing.
>> Michael Cavna: That's amazing,
you want to give her a shout out?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, yeah,
she's changed her last name by now,
Mary Connor, Mary Hendricks is
her name is now Mary Hendricks,
yeah and she you know I was
well taken care of there
and I was the only person -- I was
one of two I think in the school
who wanted to do like IB art.
So they wanted to cut it, my school
tried to cut all the art programs,
all of the kind of higher art
programs and she fought for it
for me, even though
she had to double it
with the freshman art class.
So it was like me and one other
person a little table in the corner
and then the rest she's teaching
freshman how to like make snowflakes
and not throw paint at each other.
So it was like it was, you
know it was life changing.
Yeah I'd never really had art class
before being a home schooler you
know because your parents
teach you everything you know.
I'd had like a few art
classes here and there but --
>> Michael Cavna: So good job Mary.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah and so I
mean being a shapeshifter was almost
like the best thing that I could
think of because it was just like --
I was pretty invisible there
but I didn't really know how
I was perceived and I like --
I was fine, like I just skated
through, I had my friends and we
like went to see community
theater and like old movies
because we were huge nerds but like
I definitely wanted to be the kind
of person who went to homecoming,
I mean kind of, like not enough
to actually try but like you know.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Like in my
heart I was like what would it be
like to be prom queen,
I have no idea,
literally it's the farthest thing
from my head, I don't even know most
of the kids I go to school with.
They've been going to school with
each other since they were kids
and like now I'm here, like
the hell am I, you know.
>> Michael Cavna: It's
the ultimate costume.
>> Noelle Stevenson: It is,
what if I could just try this on
and just try this on and be someone
different for just a little bit.
But like and I think teen girls
are kind of always thinking
that you know, you're like, I just
want to like be this person just
for a second and I don't
know how to be that.
And so -- and then
you know when I got
to college I had my sophomore
year was a very, very hard year,
I mean it was the year I
stopped going to church.
It was the year like -- a lot of
things happened and I just sort of,
I sort of -- it was
just hard I guess.
>> Michael Cavna: Did it feel
like a year of discovery?
>> Noelle Stevenson: It was a
year of kind of self-harm a lot,
that came out in various ways, you
know I lost a huge amount of weight
that year, in a really short period
of time and it was just like a lot
of my friends at school that year
killed themselves and it was like --
it was just like I don't
know what's going on,
I don't know which way is up, I need
some kind of hero who was as fluid
as I wished that I could be.
Who can roll with these punches and
be a literal chameleon and just fit
into every situation that she's in.
And like drawing her as chubby
was like a huge part of that,
with being like sometimes
I just want to disappear,
like I want my body to just
disappear and just having someone
who was so physically there, who
was just so loud and boisterous
and you know she had real weight.
And took up real space and that
was just, it was my way of kind
of working through all those
feelings inside myself and --
>> Michael Cavna: I
mean is brave act
of almost self-declaration
it sounds like.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: I love, you draw
transformation just beautifully,
the first time I saw that I still
remember it's just, it's so gorgeous
in one panel the way you do that so
effortlessly, is it hard to get that
or did that just flow
from your hand?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I mean
nothing ever just flows
from your hand, let's
get that straight.
>> Michael Cavna: I know.
>> Noelle Stevenson: It's never
like [inaudible] it's never
like [inaudible] purple crayon.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, exactly.
I didn't know just how honest
we were going to be here.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Nothing
ever just flows from your hand,
get used to that right now.
It doesn't mean that it
can't be a lot of fun but no,
yeah I mean I was very, very alarmed
by I think Willow traumatized me,
the part where Val
Kilmer turns into a pig.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: And it
takes him like a really long time
and it seems like it's really
painful and I was just like oooh,
same like Pinocchio where
some children were like crying
because they're turning into donkeys
and they can't even talk anymore,
they're just braying
and it's like, ahhh.
So I wanted her transformation
into animals to not be horrifying.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes, yes.
>> Noelle Stevenson: So I came up
with this idea that she's kind of,
especially since she's not really --
I came up with the idea that she
would completely deconstruct herself
before she could turn into another
form, so she would kind of turn
into this black dust and
flow into the next form.
So there wouldn't be that awkward
in between like animal stage,
where it's like I'm
a dolphin and a girl.
It's funny that I love [inaudible]
so much and I was so horrified
by the actual act and that's the
media that I was growing up with.
But yeah having the idea for
that middle period it almost was
like the death of her previous body.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: and she had
to kind of remember if she wanted
to go back to a body that she
had used before she'd have
to remember exactly
what it looked like
and build it, rebuild
it from memory.
And so she'd start getting
things wrong along the way.
And so yeah that was my, I don't
know how much of that I figured
out at the time because again
this was for a school assignment
so it was like the night
before and I was like ohhh.
>> Michael Cavna: You
put in a lot of thought
for a night before,
it's just amazing.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
You'd be surprised.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, yeah
and so again you've got the
beautiful shapes and the fact
that she is capable of this quick
violence that we don't get from --
we don't expect it from Ballister,
I mean it just seizes us.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I
mean that was my idea for her,
that was my idea for her and the
original idea for [inaudible]
when she was Nightshade was like
how does someone who just comes in
and they're not following the rules
of a typical hero villain
relationship.
So you come in with your
sidekick and they just kind
of shout peppy one liners from the
sidelines and get like attacked
by bees or something, I don't know.
And then she -- he has this
very chivalrous relationship
with his nemesis and they just
fight and then he gets arrested,
he goes to -- it's
the same every time.
She comes in and it's just like
murder, like murder immediately,
but no we did not agree on
this, what are you doing.
We don't murder people,
well I thought we did.
>> Michael Cavna: We're villains,
right, that's what we do, yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: So
yeah I mean having someone
who just breaks all the rules
immediately and just looks
so different from what the
kind of set esthetic is,
it's like no we were supposed
to wear this today and it's
like well I didn't
feel like it, you know.
>> Michael Cavna: So Nimona
is being that one is going
to be an animated film right?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: How much
creative -- yes big hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Noelle Stevenson: It
is you know it is a movie
so things happen all the time --
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah
anything can happen.
>> Noelle Stevenson: You
know it can go away tomorrow,
it can become a live action movie
starring Vin Diesel in a year.
Which I would maybe kill to see.
I'd kind of like to live
in that dark universe.
>> Michael Cavna: As long
as Vin's pants are on.
>> Noelle Stevenson: No I was
going to say the opposite.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, I know.
I was kind of like I'll say it and
if you want to take it [inaudible].
>> Noelle Stevenson: I'm
really bad at like sand casting
or like saying here's
the actor I would like --
I was like [inaudible] for
everything but when someone asks me
who I would cast for Nimona, it
was like I want Vin Diesel to play
and Ballister and [inaudible]
will both be played
by Lucy Lu wearing different wigs.
>> Michael Cavna: Nice, nice,
does Lucy know this yet?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
I haven't talked
to her recently, we got to catch up.
>> Michael Cavna: I know right.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
I'll call her for brunch.
I could tell Lucy --
>> Michael Cavna: Have your
people call her people and --
>> Noelle Stevenson: All the time.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, the a --
>> Noelle Stevenson:
I'll text her right now.
>> Michael Cavna: Wait
hold on, the [inaudible]
so how much creative control will
you have over this other than Vin
and Lucy, you know in terms
of the vision because this
like it was a movie just heard,
I mean this is coming from,
this is art as an act of not just
self-expression but affirmation
from a deep, deep place, a
sleepless place sometimes
but you know this is your baby so.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I mean
I'm really lucky when it comes to --
so far -- when it comes to
the Nimona side of things.
Like Lumberjanes I don't have
any control over but Nimona --
I'm the co-producer so I don't --
they don't really need to ask
me permission to do anything
but they kind of have to tell
me that they're doing it,
so that's really nice, so it was
like I was at the kickoff meeting.
I just have like a
bigger connection to it
and yeah I will be pretty actively
involved through the whole process.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: [Inaudible]
good but we'll see like trying
to trust these people to
do their jobs and I'll be
like oh you're doing
it wrong but go ahead.
>> Michael Cavna: and then
Lumberjanes it's again a rating
up there in Hollywood but on track
for to be a live action film, right?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Yeah, so I've heard.
>> Michael Cavna: So can you
just talk about any hopes
or any fan casting for that?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Gwendolyn Christie.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I
legitimately did tell them
that I wanted Gwendolyn Christie,
I don't know, it means nothing
to them, I don't think that
they actually passed that on.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay, well we will
text Gwendolyn and go from there.
And you do amazing sharks.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I try.
>> Michael Cavna: And
do you hear from --
because I've talked to you
know friends of young relatives
about what Nimona means to the,
you must hear from young fans,
young readers especially girls,
you know what do you
hear, what do they say?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, I
mean it's really powerful to hear
from girls who are writing from
the experience that I was kind
of writing from, you know
and the dedication is
to all the Monster girls which is
like when you're a teen girl you're
like I mean you have
a lot of power in you,
you're a monster kind of, you know.
Most of them that I know it is
you're like trying to look normal
or what you think normal should look
like but then you also have like --
in my experience a lot of anger
and a lot of fear and a lot of just
like the desire to be heard
and listened to and respected
and loved even if maybe you
know you have too many feelings
and maybe you hurt people sometimes.
So that to hear from
girls especially you know,
girls with mental illness or
who have you know something
that they feel has come
apart and this is just one
of the most -- that's
who this is for.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
that's amazing.
And anyone inspire Goldenloin,
any one person or family member
or is that just you know,
he's -- can't remember.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
I mean he's a guy.
>> Michael Cavna: A guy.
>> Noelle Stevenson: A
guy with pretty hair.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay, okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I'm sure
he's like legless at some point
in the past, legless
was my favorite.
>> Michael Cavna: Could
Lucy Lu play him?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Yes, I would love to.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Yeah [inaudible].
>> Michael Cavna: Okay
we'll make that happen.
We have just a few minutes here and
I really want you guys to be able
to ask her some questions, we
have a microphone right here
and I can't tell if we
have one over there.
>> Noelle Stevenson: It looks
like there's one over there.
>> Michael Cavna: Questions,
I think I see a hand.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
There's a hand over here.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
it's right here, go ahead.
>> What's your favorite book?
>> Noelle Stevenson: My favorite
book in the world, oh, wow.
>> Michael Cavna: I
was going to ask that.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I really liked
the Phantom Toll Booths growing up.
I read that one like every
year at around the same time,
so it's like a journey of a very
ordinary boy through a world of math
and letters and I don't remember
exactly what happened in that book.
I liked it.
>> Michael Cavna: Was
that one allowed
in the home or was that one --
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah, yeah
because it was educational.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Also Red Wall,
Red Wall was very gruesome,
do you remember that?
>> Michael Cavna: Of Course, yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Mice just
like [inaudible] each other
and that was fine, that was okay.
No problem in my house.
>> Michael Cavna: They're mice,
they're mice that harm, [inaudible].
>> What was your favorite
Scooby-Do character?
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Velma, obviously.
>> Michael Cavna: Yes.
>> Noelle Stevenson: I was one of
five, I was one of five so everyone
in my family if we ever saw like --
this is what kids do I think maybe
still, you see some character on TV
and you're like that's you.
Like there's the ugly
kid and like that's you.
So there were five of us, five
Scooby characters and they're
like you're Velma because
you're the nerd, ha.
It's like no I'm not, yes I am.
I love her and I'll still get like
personally offended if someone
like talks trash about Velma.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
so if they were
to remake Scooby-Do would you
be aboard, would you want to --
>> Noelle Stevenson: They're
always remaking Scooby-Do.
>> Michael Cavna: No I mean; no
I mean the full feature film.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
Would you make Scooby-Do?
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: In a heartbeat.
>> Michael Cavna: Okay.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: All
right, so take note, yes?
>> When did you first
get influenced to draw?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I started
drawing before I could write,
so I think I just -- I don't really
remember because I was pretty young,
I know my dad used to bring home
papers from his work that had
like numbers printed on one side and
then they were blank on the other
and I would just color on the other
side and my mom would put them
in frames and -- yeah I
must have been probably,
I don't know 4, 5,
pretty young yeah.
The almost couldn't keep
up with the amount of paper
that I wanted to draw on, yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: We'll
probably have time to work
in two more quick questions,
so right here.
>> How did you come up with the
idea for like the plot of Nimona?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I actually knew
the plot almost as soon as I knew
who Nimona was, I think the
idea that she didn't have --
that she wasn't really a girl, or
she wasn't really like a human girl,
that was like really the
seed that set it off.
And I kind of saw what the
ending was where it's like who's
to say she's not the dragon and what
do knights do, they slay dragons.
So how can I like set
up this relationship
between these three people where
you know you have the knight
or you have the hero, the villain
and the sidekick and then all
of a sudden twist those tables and
reveal that it's actually the hero,
the villain and the monster.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: And they're
not who you think they are,
so I kind of knew exactly
what was going to happen
and it evolved along the way but
I knew that she was going to have
to sort of betray Ballister at some
point and reveal that she was more
than who she seemed to be.
Yeah, spoiler, sorry if
no one has read it but,
it's really good you should read it.
>> Did you ever plan out Ballister
and Aroseous [phonetic] relationship
like from the beginning?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Yeah,
I think that was like part
of the original idea was that
like you know it's like Lex are
in Superman and they're always
like you know their faces are
like this close together and they're
like grrrr, but they like really,
really care about each other,
they follow each other everywhere
and it's like if Superman didn't
show up Lex would be really sad.
And so it's just like I wanted to
just like break down every wall
and this has this guy kind
of in love with his nemesis.
Like not, almost not ambiguously
it's just like obsessed with him,
they can't think of anything else
and they use their fight as a way
to just like hang out
with each other.
>> Also I really [inaudible].
>> Noelle Stevenson: That's a
better one that some I've heard.
>> Michael Cavna: Your
last question right here.
>> If you ever get artists or
writer's block what do you do
to make things through that.
>> Noelle Stevenson: Sometimes
I just lie on the floor,
it really down help, like lying down
just helps but now I have like a dog
and a cat so they both
come and lie on me
and so it helps less
than it used to.
My dog will literally
lie on my face so.
But I also find taking
a bath really helps,
I will just like you know
run a nice bath and hang out
and I'll be like oh I got it.
Or I'll take a walk or drive my
car anything that you're doing
where you don't have to think
too much and you can get away
from your screen or away from your
air pen and paper and just walk
around and it always helps to talk
things through, so I always have,
you know I have my friends
and they get so tired but I'm
like all right can you just
help me with this story point
and I just like talk their ear off.
And they don't almost
say anything and then I'm
like oh you're a genius
you helped me so much.
They're like I didn't say anything.
>> Michael Cavna: All
your friends are geniuses.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
They are geniuses.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah,
I think this will need
to be the last question, so yes.
>> Who inspires you the most?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Oh, wow, oooh.
>> Michael Cavna: You want to
lie down on the floor and think?
>> Noelle Stevenson: Taylor Swift.
>> Michael Cavna: Whoa, I
did not see that coming, why?
>> Noelle Stevenson: I
think Taylor Swift is going
to take over the world one day.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson:
She's a super villain.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, she
is, people think it's Trump,
it's Taylor Swift, she will.
>> Noelle Stevenson: It's going to
be totalitarian, she'll rule us all.
>> Michael Cavna: She'll say
squad goals but she is --
>> Noelle Stevenson: We
will all be in her squad.
>> Michael Cavna: The
world is her squad, yeah.
>> Noelle Stevenson: My friend
got me tickets to her concert
and we got these little wrist bands
that light up in time to the music
and as we were leaving it's like
they were still like kind flash
from time to time and I'm like
one day these are going to go off
and you know that Taylor
is summoning [inaudible].
>> Michael Cavna: And with
that we will all be there
for your squad goals, a
big hand Noelle Stevenson.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.